we have evolved through rounds of
complexity
so just like ogres have layers and
Shrink has layers humans have layers
there's the cognitive layer which is
sort of the outer you know most the the
latest evolutionary Innovation this
enormous neocortex that we have evolved
and then there's the emotional uh
baggage underneath that and then there's
all of the fear and fright and flight
and all of these kinds of behaviors so
AI only has a neocortex AI doesn't have
a limbic system it doesn't have this
complexity of human emotions which make
us so I think beautifully complex so
beautifully uh intertwined with our
emotions with our instincts with our you
know sort of gut reactions and all of
that so I think when humans are trying
to suppress that aspect the sort of code
more human aspect towards a more
cerebral aspect I think we lose a lot of
the creativity we lose a lot of the you
know freshness of humans and I think
that's quite Irreplaceable so we can
look at the entirety of people that are
alive today maybe all humans who have
ever lived yeah and mapped them in this
High dimensional space and there's
probably a center
uh a center of mass for that mapping and
a lot of us deviate in different
directions so the the variety of uh
directions in which we all deviate from
that Center is vast I would like to
think that the center is actually empty
yes that basically humans are just so
diverse from each other that there's no
such thing as an average human
that every one of us has some kind of
complex baggage of emotions intellectual
you know motivational uh behavioral
traits that
um it's not just one sort of normal
distribution we deviate from it there's
just so many dimensions that we're kind
of hitting the sort of sparseness the
the curse of dimensionality where it's
actually quite sparsely populated and I
don't think you have an average human
being so what makes us unique in part is
the diversity
and the capacity for diversity and the
capacity of the diversity comes from the
entire evolutionary history so there's
just so many ways we can vary from each
other yeah I would say not just the
capacity but the inevitability of
diversity basically it's in our Hardware
we are wired differently from each other
my siblings and I are completely
different my kids from each other
completely different my my wife has
she's like number two of six siblings
from from a distance they look the same
but then you get to you know you get to
know them every one of them is
completely different but sufficiently
the same that the differences interplay
with each other so that's the
interesting thing where the diversity is
functional it's useful so it's like
we're close enough to where we notice
the diversity and it doesn't uh
completely destroy the possibility of
like effective communication
interactions so we're still the same
kind of thing so what I said in one of
our earlier podcasts is that if humans
realize that we're 99.9 percent
identical we would basically stop
fighting with each other like we are
really one human species and we are so
so similar to each other and if you look
at the alternative if you look at the
next thing outside humans like it's been
six million years that we haven't had a
relative so it's it's truly
extraordinary that that we're we're kind
of like this Dot in outer space compared
to the rest of life on Earth